a new deal between Sudan's military and
political parties the framework
agreement aims to end the political
deadlock it allows for a new
transitional government more than a year
after the military deposed the previous
one
the reality has made us all remove
ourselves and our political interests
and place the interests of the nation
and the people above all because of that
we have agreed to sit down and came up
with what we're signing today an
agreement on the national issues that
provides a correct and strong foundation
for nation building
the transitional government will be led
by civilians not the military a prime
minister will be chosen to lead Sudan
for the two-year transitional period a
sovereign Council will manage the office
of the presidency and ministers and
lawmakers will be appointed in addition
the agreement calls for a review of the
2020 peace Accord signed between the
then transitional government and various
Rebel groups the the military group
tried to enforce their Vision they
failed and they came back to the
dialogue now our our guarantee is we
don't want to repeat the the same
mistakes and that the devastation
in Sudan vis-a-vis the political
situation the economy the security is
our uh is our what is driving all of us
towards coming together
a constitution drafting process is also
expected to be launched signatories say
the agreement paves the way to resolving
Sudan's political turmoil however not
all political parties agree several
coalitions have rejected the deal
including those that supported the
military taking power in the first place
just a few streets away from the signing
ceremony protesters gathered to voice
their concerns Security Forces use tear
gas to disperse the crowds opponents of
the agreement say it won't bring
stability
the political party signing the deal
have refused for a long time to
negotiate with us and reach a deal we've
asked them to postpone the deal so we
can reach an agreement and iron out our
differences but they've refused this
agreement comes against the will of the
people and will be a divisive point
s are expected between the military and
signatories to the agreement they say
there is still time for those who have
rejected the deal to reconsider Heber
Morgan Al Jazeera Khartoum